this routine iconic and let's forget two
health issues that's obvious we're gonna
focus on this part right here
it seems that cigarette litter is the
last acceptable form of littering it's
also one of the most littered plastic
items on this planet so breathe that in
for a second
[Music]
cigarettes weren't always so popular
here's what happened before 1888 took a
really long time to roll a cigarette but
then this guy invented the rolling
machine and after that between 1900 and
1960 three American adults went from
smoking an average of 54 cigarettes a
year to 4,000 the tobacco companies
invested heavily into marketing
celebrities athletes models made smoking
seem sexy healthy an essential part of
American culture
[Music]
but then in January 1964 a bombshell
report was released the report is
unanimous the death rate from lung
cancer is 1,000% higher among people who
smoke this is when the filter really
took off
tobacco companies transitioned to
marketing it as a way to reduce smoking
hazards today with more than 6 trillion
cigarettes being manufactured every year
that filter made from cellulose acetate
aka plastic became one of the most
littered plastic items in the world
ending up here here and here in New
Jersey
CIN D Y Z as in zebra IPAs and pollution
F as in fish in the mid 80s New Jersey
was the ocean dumping capital of the
world sewage sludge medical waste these
were terrible terrible times for the
region in 1984 Cindy helps start clean
ocean action and along with it organized
one of the nation's first Beach sweeps
like the one you see here we have all
the all the data in here what we
collected last year in just two days
almost 22,000 cigarette
data like that is the reason Cindy's
team has been able to influence policy
change by 2002 New Jersey was dumpsite
free for the first time in 100 years but
they still have a lot of work to do our
society has evolved and not such a
positive way over time when looking at
the beach sweep data over 80 percent
right now is plastic debris on the
beaches the good news is that Cindy's
data shows that cigarette filters found
on beaches have declined over the last
few years however according to the World
Health Organization cigarette butts are
still the number one item picked up on
beaches worldwide the bad news vaping is
quickly gaining popularity and the
cartridges and tips use with these
products are becoming the next iteration
single-use plastic trash so here's what
we can do about it
[Music]
the best solution get everyone to stop
smoking which probably won't work the
government could help here cigarette
disposal cost cities millions each year
since 93 over 150 beaches in the u.s.
implemented smoking bans which in one
case study led to fewer cigarette butts
but federally we've yet to see any type
of regulation some companies claim
they've created a completely
biodegradable filter but there's no hard
science backing them up other solutions
include filterless roll your own
cigarettes pocket ashtrays or reusable
filters but back to what Cindy said
cigarette litter is the last acceptable
form of littering the key word here is
acceptable social norms play a huge role
in our behavior if society thinks it's
even a little bit okay we're gonna do it
regardless of the impact nowadays
especially in the age of social media
public opinion can shift quicker than
ever just look at plastic straws so
maybe the best solution might just be to
make littering a cigarette but socially
unacceptable
[Laughter]
[Music]
you